بعد يومين واحد فقط من اعلان القوه
الكرديه في شمال سوريا عن اطلاق عمليه
الامنيه ضد المجموعات المسلحه في شرق
سوريا تحديدا اثنا عشر عاما من حقل تيم
النفطي في ريفي دير الزور الغربي لقتله في
هجوم جديد استادف حافلاتهم فجر اليوم
المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان عناصر من
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه نفذ الهجوم بعبوه
الناسفات ثم اطلقوا النار على الحافلات
الهجوم وقعه في اجزاء دير الزور التي تقع
تحت سيطره الحكومه السوريه
من كومنتري معانا الان مدير المرصد السوري
لحقوق الانسان رامي عبد الرحمن اهلا بك
سيد رامي بدايه هل من حصيله جديده تغيرت
ربما لهذا الهجوم وتفاصل اخرى اتضحت بعد
ساعه من وقوعه
صباح الخير طبعا بعد ساعات من الوقوع هي
الحصيره بالنسبه الحسين
استشهدوا على يد عناصر تنظيم داعش في هجوم
في الباديه السوريه طبعا بعد الهجوم كان
هناك استنفار وحتى اللحظه استنثار همم
دير الزور دمشق في داخل مدينه دير الزور
وفي محيط المطار خوفا من عمليات جديده
لتنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه التي شدنا هذا
الشهر لوحده 14 عمليه ضد قوات النظام
لها ادت ل همم مقتل ماذا يقول عن الاسلام
واربعون عصرا من هذه واقف بالاضافه
لاستشار سن 13 مدنيا اخرهم عمال النفط
الذين استشهدوا في هذا الكمين لتنظيم داعش
في الباديه السوريه التنظيم هذا من جديد
هذا الشهر ليضرب بقوه في كامل الباديه
السوريه بالاضافه للهجمات التي يشنها في
مناطق سيطره قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
نفهم معك يعني السبب هذا العوده لتنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه وهذا الهجوم الجديد هل
من تفسير ربما يتعلق بهذا تقارب السوري
همم التركي التركي
عن هجمات تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه بعد ان
كانوا في المواجهه بشكل قوي اذا هذا
التنظيم على هذا التقارب السوري التركي
جبهات شرق الفرات يوجد فيها قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وايضا تشم فيها التنظيمه
جماعه الداميه حقيقه امام اخرها الذي كان
ليس اثر اكثرها نبويا كان الذي كان في
مدينه الرقه ولكن التنظيم في مناطق في
السيطره الطوبار سوريا الديمقراطيه نفذ 25
هجوما على الاقل في هذا الشهر لوحده بعد
التصريحات التركيه عن عمليه عسكريه اعتقد
الامر لا يرتبط في موضوع التقارب السوري
التركي يرتبط بامير داعش الجديد بخليفه
داعش الجديد الذي معه وجوده بدات عمليات
تتصاعد بشكل كبير جدا داخل التراب السوري
بين الخطيرات الشرقيه والغربيه شكرا جزيلا
لك سيدنا عبد الرحمن مدير استاذ السوري
لحقوق الانسان بريطانيا